we're learning more this morning about
an attack on American forces and our
allies in Syria that's being linked to
the Russian government it happened
February 7th and resulted in a number of
Russian mercenaries being killed the
Russians were reportedly working for
oligarchy Evgeny prigogine a close ally
of President Vladimir Putin Prigogine is
the same man accused of running a troll
factory that targeted American voters
Elizabeth Palmer is in Moscow and has
new details on the Syrian attack and the
role of the Russians Elizabeth good
morning good morning when the US
soldiers called in there those
airstrikes to defend themselves they had
no idea that they were going to end up
killing and wounding dozens of Russian
citizens now the Pentagon has released a
video of two of those attacks their own
airstrikes I mean and they show some of
the mercenaries and also one of their
tanks activists here say that they were
either in the process of are about to
attack a gas installation where US
Special Forces were already dug in with
their Kurdish allies the mercenaries
essentially Afghani promotions private
army had been sent to Syria originally
to back up the Russian military but more
recently it seems they cut a deal with
the Syrian government to try and take
over oil and gas fields in Syria in
return for a cut of the profits now it
wasn't until Facebook photographs over
photographs of some of the men killed in
those airstrikes started to show up on
social media including Facebook here
that the Pentagon realized that it had
killed Russian citizens Georgian much
more than just Putin chef but Liz isn't
there a hot line between the Russian
military and US forces that's supposed
to avoid these types of incidents yes
there is that's the amazing thing the
Pentagon says they actually called the
Russians before the strike and they said
we're going to do this and the Russians
didn't warn them off they didn't say
don't do it it's our guys so presumably
the Russian military is not happy that a
private oligarch army is out there
operating on what's already a very
complex battlefield
the risk of escalation as we now see
hugely hi glad Amir Putin trying to play
it down thus far less Palmer in Moscow
thank you